JOAN CANNON: I would like to thank--
CALEB BRADFORD: I want to thank--
ISABELLE NOGUES: I'd like to thank--
GAVIN COOK: I'm immensely thankful
to a lot of people.
JONATHAN GLASSMAN:
First and foremost,
would be my parents, my
dad who always reminded me
how to take things cool, you
know, work first, panic later.
BENJAMIN HAZEL: My
parents, my family--
JOAN CANNON: My parents for
financially supporting me.
SARAH ISLAM: My
parents, who have just
been so incredibly supportive
about my nontraditional goals.
VIVIEN CHENG: My
parents, my grandparents
for believing in
me and for being
people that like I can
believe in and be inspired by.
CHRISTIAN SAHNER: My
family, who have tolerated
many, many years of
esoteric conversation
at the dining room table.
ALLISON METTS: My
sister, Elizabeth Metts,
thank you for showing me that
graduating from Princeton
is possible, that
writing a thesis
is possible, that having a
life while writing a thesis
is possible.
CALEB BRADFORD: My dad,
first and foremost,
for raising me and
always believing in me.
BENJAMIN HAZEL: My
brother, especially.
I want to thank my teammates for
being there through everything.
GAVIN COOK: My family.
They've given me gifts
of such great magnitude
and I'm only beginning
to understand exactly how
wonderful they are now.
ISABELLE NOGUES: All
of my professors,
advisers, college deans,
residential advisers--
BENJAMIN HAZEL: Grandma--
VIVIEN CHENG: You know, all my
teachers from before college,
because they're who
shaped me into someone who
could be accepted by Princeton.
SARAH ISLAM: My husband as
well, who has been so patient.
Graduate school is a--
anyone in graduate school,
anyone who is in
graduate school will
be able to tell you that it is
a totally different ballgame.
It is not just a full-time job.
It's like three full-time jobs.
JONATHAN GLASSMAN:
My mom who, you know,
really inspired me to keep
fighting through the mess.
My brother, also a PhD student,
huge inspiration, and my sister
as well.
JOAN CANNON: I want
to thank my peers
for both encouraging
and challenging me
in my academics and
extracurricular activities.
BENJAMIN HAZEL: I want
to give a special thanks
to Rachel Ferguson for
doing everything that she
did in my thesis process.
GAVIN COOK: I want to thank
the entire East Asian Studies
department.
It was a blast being
a major and I can't
recommend it highly enough.
CALEB BRADFORD: My high school
college and career counselor
Mrs. Roberts.
VIVIEN CHENG: The
Admissions office
because I don't know who
was reading my applications,
but they made the decision
and they give me the opportunity
to come to a university
like this.
CHRISTIAN SAHNER: My advisers,
Professor Peter Brown
in the Department of History,
and Professor Michael Cook
in the Department of
Near Eastern Studies, who
have been wonderful mentors and
examples of intellectual life
for me.
ISABELLE NOGUES: Mentor
Doctor Christine Taylor,
who has guided me through
numerous processes
in my upperclassmen
years in math.
JONATHAN GLASSMAN: My
undergraduate research adviser
Professor Maria Feng,
who if it wasn't for her
I wouldn't have even considered
going to grad school.
CALEB BRADFORD: For my
seventh grade language arts
teacher, Mrs. Carlson.
SARAH ISLAM: My
adviser, Professor Cook.
GAVIN COOK: I want
to thank my friends
on campus for their
inspiration and support.
And a friend of mine
from high school
whose name is Brendan Kutler.
He's since passed away and he's
taught me so much in his life
and in his passing.
VIVIEN CHENG: My professors,
my advisers, the staff,
the admins of the
Music Department.
BENJAMIN HAZEL: I also want
to thank my other thesis
adviser Professor Lawrence.
VIVIEN CHENG: --the
Wilson College office--
JONATHAN GLASSMAN: In addition
to the many grad students
along the way and
the undergraduates
that I have advised
who got me through some
of the rough moments,
and also made
sure I enjoyed the fun moments.
Last, but not
least, is definitely
my own adviser,
Professor Maria Garlock,
who inspires me not only as an
academic and as an engineer,
but actually how to
be a better person.
CALEB BRADFORD: I have to thank
all the professors and students
in MAE.
It's certainly been a team
effort getting to graduation.
And I've had an extraordinary
experience building projects,
also building friendships
in the process.
VIVIEN CHENG: --the Neuroscience
Department, and also OIP,
the Office of International--
like the Study Abroad Programs.
CHRISTIAN SAHNER: For
me the unsung heroes
of Princeton's campus
are its chaplains.
And I profited tremendously
from the wonderful priests
of the Aquinas Institute,
Princeton's Roman
Catholic chaplaincy,
who have supported me
through many years of tough
work of all the challenges
that this wonderful
place throws at you.
VIVIEN CHENG: --the
private music teachers
that I studied with.
GAVIN COOK: I want to
thank Professor David
Leheny, my thesis adviser.
CALEB BRADFORD: Thanks go to my
loving friends and family who
through the good and the bad,
successes and failures,
never fail to keep
my ego in check
and help pick me up
when I need it most.
CHRISTIAN SAHNER: I feel like
this is a family victory -- not
my achievement, but
really it belongs
to my mother, my father,
my brother, and my sister.
[MUSIC PLAYING]